CANDICE HOYES: Hi,
I'm Candace Hoyes.
And right now, we're
backstage at Talks at Google.
I can't wait to get started.
I'm having a great time.
And if you enjoy
the music, please
don't forget to comment
in the comments section
and subscribe to
Talks at Google so you
can see more shows like this.
If you want to follow me, follow
me at @CandiceHoyes on Twitter,
and at @CandiceHoyes1
on Instagram.
I'll see you inside.
ANDREW RALLES: Welcome everyone,
to Talks at Google New York.
My name is Andrew Ralles.
Our guest today is jazz
vocalist Candice Hoyes.
She's here to speak to
us about her debut album,
entitled "On a Turquoise Cloud."
On the album, Candice interprets
some very rare Duke Ellington
songs that are definitely
worthy of a lot more attention.
So I'm so excited
that she's here
to share her music with us.
I also wanted to mention that
I was introduced to Candice
by another Googler by the
name of Ben Tarbell, who
works out of our Mountain View
office on the Energy Team.
A really great guy.
I'm just so happy that he
connected me with Candice.
And I've enjoyed
getting to know her
during the planning
of this event.
She just has such an
amazing story and path
to get to this point.
And I'll give you a
little bit of background
about her musical history.
She started on the
piano at the age of six.
Got her start singing
professionally in children's
theater at the age of 11.
She graduated from Harvard
University with honors.
She also has a Master's
Degree in Voice Performance
and Pedagogy from Westminster
Choir College in Princeton, New
Jersey.
She is a classically
trained singer, a soprano.
She's done opera and has
performed in six languages.
She's sung internationally
at festivals.
Has performed here in New
York City at Lincoln Center
and Carnegie Hall, as well.
Again, so happy that she's here.
Please give a warm
welcome to Candice Hoyes.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd love for you to tell
everyone about the album
and just how you were drawn to
the material and a little bit
about how the concept of "On a
Turquoise Could" came together.
CANDICE HOYES: Well, it was
really a labor of love for me,
I'd say.
And this is my debut album.
So it's been such an
exciting journey for me.
As you mentioned, I have
a liberal arts background.
And certainly,
history is something
that's always inspired me.
And I'd say Duke
Ellington is, for me,
the most prolific and
most quintessential
American composer.
And I do have a
classical training.
But one of the most
pivotal moments for me
was singing with Jazz
at Lincoln Center
a couple years ago on a very
special project that was
composed by Wynton Marsalis.
And that's someone that I've
always really looked up to,
as someone who has never
been impeded by a genre.
He's a foremost jazz
musician, for anyone
who's not familiar with
him, amazing trumpeter.
But he also draws from
many musical influences,
as I always have.
And so when I did that
gig, I just started really
opening my mind, like what
could my first album be about?
What could be the
subject matter?
And so I did go back
to Duke Ellington.
And it's been a lifelong
source of musical inspiration.
He's such a innovator.
And I started
exploring these songs
and come to find
through research, which
is where the good liberal
arts background comes in,
no one's recorded them, many
of them, since Ellington.
So we are the first of our
generation to share these.
I say we because some of
these amazing musicians
recorded the album with
me, arranged to play it on.
And we certainly are living it
out as we tour all of-- these
are some of my
favorite musicians.
So it's just been
an amazing journey.
And every time I tour and
every time I go to a new place,
it's Duke Ellington.
But I'm bringing something
very undiscovered.
So it's a discovery for me.
And then it becomes a
discovery for the audience.
So it was really an
exciting time for me.
ANDREW RALLES: It's just
absolutely beautiful music.
And I can't wait for you
to play a couple of tunes
from the album.
But just on the
topic of discovery,
there are some songs on it
that maybe a lot of people
never heard before.
I think they're lesser known
than some of Duke Ellington's
other material.
But in particular,
he wrote a few songs
for classically
trained sopranos.
And I'd love for you to talk
a little bit about the women
in the original recordings
and your connection to them.
CANDICE HOYES: Well, that really
touches on more people who've
very much inspired me.
There was one
particular vocalist
who Duke Ellington
really discovered.
And her name is Kay Davis.
And she was a classically
trained vocalist,
much like myself.
Went to Northwestern in the '40s
and did her musical training
in the time when
conservatory was segregated.
So she was one of the
stars of her class
and was chosen to
be very featured
in her senior performance
opposite a white tenor.
And that was controversial
on that campus.
And this is Chicago.
It's not even the Deep South.
And by great fortune,
Duke Ellington
came to hear her perform
her senior recital
and discovered her talent.
And whereas she was encountering
those obstacles in the academy
and in classical music,
Ellington just saw the talent
and saw that she had
something to say.
And so he brought
her into the band.
And as you know, Andrew,
with your musical background,
a lot of jazz musicians start
so very early on the road,
especially in those days.
So she really was coming from
the conservatory environment
and just hit the road, traveled
through the Jim Crow South
with the Duke Ellington
band, the only lady
in the band for a
great stretch of time.
And Ellington started to
compose for her voice.
And so he wrote "On
a Turquoise Cloud,"
for which I've named the album.
And it's a wordless vocalise.
A vocalise is a classical
term of art describing using
the voice like an instrument.
And so there are no words.
And just the vocal
musical texture
joins into the
texture of the band.
And so for me, that kind
of assimilation musically,
it has a lot to do with
how I feel about the album
because I feel like
I'm going through that.
So it was a perfect
name for the album.
But it's also a
way of remembering
Kay Davis and a way of
acknowledging what Ellington
did for artists like me, who
don't really have a category.
ANDREW RALLES: OK, thank you.
And I think we have
some images of Kay
and a few of the other singers.
CANDICE HOYES: Yes, that's
Kay Davis in the middle.
Oh, it's labeled.
That's even better.
Adelaide Hall, Adelaide
Hall in the '20s.
And we're going to play
it one of those tunes
that she made famous
called "Creole Love Call"
when we start playing.
And many people say that she
is the first person to scat.
But her scatting was in that
soprano range and growling.
And so those are
some jazz terms.
But basically, it
means there was
a lot of freedom and
improvisation in her singing.
But she was also a great lady
of musical theater and stage
and cabaret.
And Alice Babs
hails from Norway.
No, Sweden.
I'm sorry.
Sweden, but Ellington was such
a international musical figure
that he really pulled his
voices and inspirations much
as we do in this world, in 2016.
It's a global experience.
Tech is a global experience.
In music too.
And so he had so
many influences.
So we actually deal with
that music on the album too.
ANDREW RALLES: OK, great.
Well, why don't we hear a
couple of songs from the album?
Are we ready to--
CANDICE HOYES: I'm ready.
Are you guys ready?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[SINGING "BABY" BY DUKE
ELLINGTON]
[PIANO SOLO]
[BASS SOLO]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So this next one is really
essential to the album.
It's the title track.
And it's called "On
a Turquoise Cloud."
MUSICIAN: Two, three, four.
[PIANO PLAYING]
[HUMMING "ON A TURQUOISE CLOUD"
BY DUKE ELLINGTON]
[PIANO SOLO]
[HUMMING]
[APPLAUSE]
CANDICE HOYES: Thank you.
I'd now like to
bring to the stage
another very essential
part of this album, someone
that I actually toured
with Wynton Marsalis
with when I mentioned
I had that very kind
of formative experience
with Jazz at Lincoln Center
orchestra.
And he's an amazing collaborator
who came onto this project
and arranged music
for the album.
And this is our very
special, special musician,
Vincent Gardner on trombone.
[APPLAUSE]
And this tune is very
special because it's actually
Duke Ellington's first
international hit.
And it started in 1927,
when Ellington composed
this tune, inspired
by another song
from a musical called
"Indian Love Call."
And he called it
"Creole Love Call."
Jazz was actually born in New
Orleans, as many of you know.
And so he was really
claiming that piece
of music, that musical idea
that was really popular
and appropriating it for jazz
and really putting his spin
on it and calling it
"Creole Love Call."
And originally, Billy
Strayhorn wrote those lyrics.
And he wrote them
about-- the lyrics
are like, [SINGING] "My love,
my love, my love, my love,
I see you across
the swamp my love."
Something like that.
And I'm from Florida.
But the swamp wasn't
really turning me on.
So [LAUGHS] I said, I'm going
to write some lyrics for this.
And so they do come from a
little bit of life experience.
So without any further ado,
this is "Creole Love Call."
MUSICIAN: [SNAPPING FINGERS]
[PLAYING MUSIC]
[SINGING "CREOLE LOVE CALL" BY
DUKE ELLINGTON]
[TROMBONE SOLO]
[PIANO SOLO]
[BASS SOLO]
[SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Wow, these lunches fly by.
But I'm so glad
that you're here.
And so we're going to
share one more with you.
But you can certainly follow me.
I'm high tech.
I'm low tech with
acoustic vocals
and the classical
and jazz singing.
But I'm high tech.
And you can certainly follow
me on all the social things
and come out to more
shows and hear us.
But we're so glad to be here.
We thank you for welcoming us
to Google and Talks at Google.
And this last tune
is very special to me
because it really expresses
the whirlwind of emotion when
you release your first album
and all the amazing people
that you meet along the way and
the wonderful musicians that
become more like family than
colleagues or even friends.
And Duke Ellington actually
had a very specific bond
with one particular musician
throughout his entire-- well,
from the moment
they met, they were
kind of musically
inseparable, Billy Strayhorn.
And so this melody, it's one of
the most famous jazz melodies.
People know it as
"Lotus Blossom."
But upon the death,
they added lyrics.
Well, Alice Babs
and her collaborator
added lyrics to
this melody to make
it a tribute to Duke Ellington.
And so it's a really
beautiful tune called
"Thank You for Everything."
[PIANO PLAYING]
[SINGING "THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING" BY DUKE ELLINGTON]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Give it up one more time,
even more of Google.
Double that for Adam
Birnbaum on the piano,
Yasushi Nakamura on the bass,
Jake Goldblas on the drums,
and my special guest, Vincent
Gardner on the trombone.
Much love.
[APPLAUSE]
Going to have some time
for some questions, I hope.
ANDREW RALLES:
Let's do some Q&A.
We have microphones lined
up in the aisles here.
If you have your questions
ready, mics are open.
CANDICE HOYES: Even if you
don't have your questions ready
and you just want to
say hello, tell me
how you liked the music.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious
about a couple of things.
One was I've never
heard any jazz
with the kind of
vocalization that you
did in "On a Turquoise Cloud."
Is that a unique piece?
Or are there other pieces
done with that kind of vocals,
either by Ellington
or other composers?
CANDICE HOYES: There
really are, actually.
I did my research for this album
by going back to this source.
So I went to the National
Archive and researched Duke
Ellington and had
his manuscripts
in my hand, the actual penciled
manuscripts, transcribed, some,
by Billy Strayhorn.
And I found about 30 songs.
So it was really
quite eye-opening.
But they definitely exist.
And I tend to think that
many classical and jazz
and musical theater
compositions of today
are so influenced by this
kind of improvisatory use
of that high range.
I mean, a lot of people,
even from Minnie Riperton,
a soul singer that so many
people know, use that range.
And so it is something
that's really, I think,
continued in the music.
But it is particular
to Ellington.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for the performance.
I had a question I hadn't
thought about until you
started performing.
You had at least two
songs with new lyrics
or new interpretations beyond
just the usual interpretation.
And I wondered when you were
researching and preparing
the albums, did you have
any trepidations about that?
Because it's not that jazz
is sacred in the sense
that it never changes
because it's always changing.
But when you're
dealing with something
like Ellington's
music or Strayhorn,
I'm sure there's a body
of people out there
who probably don't
want any changes.
It's like, this is
the classic jazz.
CANDICE HOYES: Oh, you
met some of the people
that I met along the way.
AUDIENCE: No, I just--
CANDICE HOYES: It's true.
AUDIENCE: It's just that when
I was first got interested
in jazz, it always was an issue.
I got interested in jazz
when the avant garde
was coming along.
And it was a big
all-nighter type topic
of whether you know Archie
Shepp or whoever it would be,
Cecil Taylor, whether they
were on the right track
or they were just almost
like the French avante garde,
just tearing down the old movies
so that their movies could
come in.
The same concept in jazz.
You had the traditional
jazz artists and then
this new group coming in.
I'm not trying to make
this controversial.
But I wondered if this
was an issue for you.
CANDICE HOYES: Oh, you hit
on the heart of the matter.
The question is, if
I had any trepidation
about really putting my
stamp on Duke Ellington
music and Strayhorn
music on my first album.
And yes, it did
take some courage.
And it's a journey
that I continue to-- it
continues to challenge me.
But it's also the very joy and
the very opportunity of jazz
is that--
Actually, when Vincent
and I were on tour,
we ended up talking a
lot about that, and some
of our other colleagues,
that there's really
an onus for all musicians,
especially jazz musicians,
I feel, I believe, to record
and put your stamp on it
and to leave your
mark in this legacy.
And then I feel like I doubled
down on that sense of purpose
when I got to the Archive and
saw that these manuscripts--
first of all, they didn't
exist as lead sheets.
So that means, for the layman,
that we as vocalists couldn't
even really choose them.
They weren't really an option.
So they had to be transformed.
And they had to be transformed
by somebody who loved the music
and believed in it.
And I said, that's me.
And so it was a
very humble process.
It continues to be
a humble process
because I revere those artists.
But it's very much
what I was meant to do.
So I can't imagine
it any other way.
ANDREW RALLES: Do we
have another question?
CANDICE HOYES: Yes, hello.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yes, other than the
National Archives,
where does one look
for unpublished
or unrecorded
Ellington repertoire?
CANDICE HOYES: So
one of the privileges
of this album, because
it's such classic music
and it's so innovative
and its life.
It's not new.
But I was actually
thinking about this a lot
when I was thinking about
coming to Google today,
the difference
between my generation
is always looking at the new.
And I was thinking,
this album, as you said,
it's music that I recovered.
But sometimes innovation
doesn't come out of newness.
Right?
Sometimes it comes out
of repurposing something
that exists already.
And so with that
said, this music
has brought me to
all different spaces,
not just Google, but also this
huge international Ellington
convention that I attended
earlier this season.
And honestly, the
National Archive
is just the tip of the iceberg
for finding rare Ellington
material.
Some of my greatest sources
were through the oral tradition.
We had the privilege
of recording
with a dear friend and
someone we revere very much,
Joe Temperley.
He's an amazing
artist and actually
recorded one of his signature
songs on this album with us,
which was a great privilege.
And he imparted a
lot of information
about Ellington
and rare Ellington.
So just through
the oral tradition,
you can get a lot
of information.
People present me with
DVDs of Ellington's films.
For me, for one of the songs, I
didn't find it in the Archive,
for "Violet Blue."
Actually, there is no real
vocal manuscript available.
And so I had to extract
the sound using tech.
I had to extract the sound
from a old movie clip.
So I think anywhere that you're
curious to find Ellington,
you can find a lot of gems.
ANDREW RALLES: One more.
CANDICE HOYES: Oh, don't be shy.
Come on.
AUDIENCE: Well, so in the
process of that research,
do you imagine maybe
there's undiscovered
Miles Davis or Charlie
Parker or whatever out there?
Are you thinking of
doing anything like that?
Or are you going to
stick with Ellington?
CANDICE HOYES: Oh,
well, I would say I'm
going to stick with all of it.
Your question was
like, what would I see
for a future project upcoming.
I will always be culling through
the artists who influenced me,
including, yes, Miles Davis.
There are many
artists wh0 ranging
from Stevie Wonder, Yo-Yo Ma.
I have a lot of
different influences.
I don't know what my
next project will be,
if it will be about rare works.
But it's certainly something
I'm very interested in
because I think that,
as young musicians,
it's important to enjoy that
music and really gain from it
all the inspiration
that is in it
and to share it with our
peers in this generation.
And so it's a part of
my purpose, I feel like.
It probably will be a part
of everything that I do.
But as far as the
particulars, I think
the next project will probably
have more of my writing on it.
AUDIENCE: So I was also curious.
I mean, do you
think other artists,
like, in the National
Archive or other places,
that there are more of these
kinds of undiscovered tunes
out there?
CANDICE HOYES: Are more
undiscovered tunes?
Absolutely.
And as I was mentioning
before, there
are so many ways
to describe them.
Some of them are just by hearing
live music and meeting players
and getting clues as to,
oh, did you check out
this recording of that?
And that can lead
you to the music
that you've never heard of.
But yes, I mean, there
certainly is rare music
being discovered all
the time because there
are a lot of people
who are very-- not just
me-- very passionate
about chasing it down.
ANDREW RALLES: OK, well, I think
we're just about out of time
here.
But thanks so much to
Candice and her amazing band,
the Talks at Google
team, and all of you
for joining us today.
Have a great rest of the day.
CANDICE HOYES: Thank you.
Thanks, Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]